i would argue any human being watching  this right now is obnoxiously lucky your  parents had sex at the exact right  second to make you a human being 400  trillion to one modern scientist  mathematical odds of being a human being  i don't want to hear a word from  anybody's [ __ ] mouth everyone's lucky  your mom could have got up for another  glass of wine and you wouldn't exist i  mean that conversation is ridiculous  there's people who literally had a tree  fall in her head today they were unlucky  i was [ __ ] i'm the luckiest i was  born in the soviet union a [ __ ]  [ __ ] and [ __ ] was able to be  traded for wheat because of a lucky  moment in cold war history ended up in  america the entrepreneurial heaven of  all time as an entrepreneur i'm 100  lucky my big thing to my friends and  acquaintances and strangers who use luck  as a weapon to make themselves feel  better is okay and now what did that  make you feel better cool we're all  lucky now what